NINETEEN PRECAUTIONS WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
IN THE CHAMBER AND ROTH CAPITAL.
SO WE ARE ONLY BLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING PERSON. MASKER
REQUIRED FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
AND IN THE HEARING AND
THROUGHOUT CAPITOL GROUNDS. YOU
CAN TESTIFY IN PERSON. VIA
VIDEOCONFERENCE FROM CAPITAL
ONE TWENTY FIVE OR BY PHONE.
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION IS
NOT AVAILABLE TODAY. THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWENTY FOUR
TO SIX TO THIRTY SEVEN. THIS
NUMBER CAN BE FOUND ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND IS
DISPLAYED ON YOUR SCREENS. FOR
THOSE CALLING IN PLEASE MAKE
YOURSELVES WELL IN THE QUEUE TO
ELIMINATE BACKGROUND NOISE.
REACH BILL HEARD TODAY THERE
WILL BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION RIGHT
TWO MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES CALLING IN
YOU WILL BE PLACED IN A QUEUE
UNTIL YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL BE ALTERNATED.
WHEN IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENT. S. ONE THEN
ZERO AND- YOU YOURSELVES IN
ORDER TO SPEAK. PLEASE BE BRIEF
LIMITING TO YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
TO YOUR NAME. ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FRAZIER PRESIDENT. BIGELOW
PRESIDENT AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN
BARRIO. COOLEY COOPER DALY.
DAVIES GALLAGHER. EDUARDO
GARCIA. GIPSON JONES SAWYER.
BLACKIE MATHIS. QUICKSILVER
RAMOS. FROM ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO. SALAS SMITH. WE
HAVE TO DRAW. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY WILL GOING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY BEFORE THIRTY TWO HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. THE
MEMBERS FOR FUTURE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS PLEASE NOTE. THE
PUBLIC ALSO EMILY GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE RULES
THE DEADLINE FOR POSITION
LETTERS IS SIX CALENDAR DAYS
PRIOR TO THE HEARING IN ORDER
TO BE REFLECTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. I REPEAT
SIX CALENDAR DAYS. WHAT WE WILL
HAVE A NOTICEABLY MEMBER THAT
YOU WOULD DO. DO WHAT. IS
REPLACING- ASSEMBLY LOOK MEMBER
LOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO
IS REPLACING ASSEMBLY MENTOR
NUMBER BONTA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. MOVE ON TO THE
CONSECUTIVE YEARS ON CONSENT AB
ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN BIGELOW AB
THIRTY THREE FIFTY ONE CRISTINA
GARCIA AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. FIFTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT AND AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY NINE OR ALL GEO
COMMITTEE BILLS ON CONSENT IS
THERE A MOTION. MISTER GIBSON
AND- DAVID DAVIS OF FOR THE
MOTION THAT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
FILE. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER HI BIGELOW
HI BIGELOW HI AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN. CORREO
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER
AYE DALY DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES
AYE GARCIA. GARCIA AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON I JONES SAWYER. LACKING
LACKEY I MATHIS. MATHIS II CORK
SILVA. RAMOS. RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RUBIO. SALAS SALAS I SMITH.
SMITH IV ARE PUT OFF. BY. HAS
FIFTEEN ELEVEN OPEN FIFTY.
BECAUSE THE KILLER HAS FIFTY
VOTE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FROM MOST I. THANK YOU
MINUTES AFTER. ALSO WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON WHO A ITEM NUMBER ONE
FILE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE NINE. AUTHORS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REGULAR UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE A DISTRICT REGIONAL BILL
FOR US. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB FIVE FIVE NINE WILL
ADD NEW AND UNDER REPRESENTED
VOICES TO THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY BOARD HE WILL
RESPECT FRAME THE FOCUS OF
COUNTY RESIDENTS SEATS AND
ENSURE THAT THE BOARD IS FULLY
SEATED. AND MAKE OTHER CHANGES
TO ALIGN ITS OPERATION AS THE
STATE AGENCY ALONGSIDE OTHER
CONSERVANCY. PUBLIC PARKS IN
AND AROUND URBAN AREAS ARE
CRUCIAL FOR BOTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE THE
PANDEMIC HAS MADE IT CLEAR BOTH
THE NEED FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THESE SPACES.
AS WELL AS THE SEVERE LACK OF
ACCESS MANY OF OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE.
RESIDENTS IN UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS FRESNO AND
MADERA COUNTIES FACE JUST SUCH
A PREDICAMENT. THANKFULLY THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY'S
MISSION TO ACQUIRE LANDS ALONG
THESAN JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVE
VALUABLE HABITAT AND DEVELOP
THESE LANDS FOR THE PUBLIC'S
BENEFIT IS A CURE TO THIS LACK
OF ACCESS. HOWEVER TO PROVIDE
THE MAXIMUM BENEFITS TO ALL
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT DIVERSE AND
MARGINALIZED VOICES AND
PERSPECTIVES HELP GUIDE THE
DECISIONS THE CONSERVANCY'S
MAKE IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER. AB
FIVE FIVE NINE EXPANDS THE
CONSERVANCY BOARD TO INCLUDE
THESE NEW VOICES TO REPRESENT
BOTH THE BROAD GEOGRAPHIC AND
CULTURAL DIVERSITY THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER PARKWAY SERVES.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
MAYOR SANTOS GARCIA OF THE CITY
OF MADERA AS WELL AS JOHN
SHELTON THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY WHO CAN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT BOARD
OPERATIONS. MAY WE HEAR FROM
THE FIRST- MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
THE FIRST WITNESS IN THE QUEUE.
I APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO WITNESSES ON THE
TELEPHONE AT THIS TIME. YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES ARE
DOCTOR REGULAR OF FOR THIS
BILL. NO SIR SO WHAT WE WILL IS
IN THE PROCESS OF THAT. WHEN
THIS DOES COME UP IN THE QUEUE
WE WILL ASK A MODERATOR TO LET
US KNOW OKAY. CARRETERA FAT
WHAT DOES HAPPEN TO PRESENT
HIMSELF. PLEASE LET US KNOW SO
WE CAN. AT LEAST LET THEM. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. SERVE THE
AUTHORS BILLS. WITHOUT GONNA ON.
THE IN THE WITH THE ANYBODY THE
CHANCE THE HAS THE UPPER. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
SEEING NONE. IN THAT SHE WITH
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE. AS WE SAID THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE- IS NOT
OPERABLE TODAY. SO WHAT WE WILL
DO THE MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE- THE PHONE SO HELLO
FOR OPPOSITE- EXCUSE ME SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL. THANK YOU
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A
STATEMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
FIVE NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AGAIN SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE
FIVE NINE YOU PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OKAY OVER. NINE TO
SIXTY FIVE TWO SIX FIVE THIS IS
THE BILL YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO.
YEAH. THANK YOU LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH- HI
MY NAME IS ALAN MORALITY AND I
OWN AND OPERATE DOUBLE COPY AT
FIVE SIX TWO NINE NORTH THE
GIRL IT'S PRETTY. A LOT TEN OF
NINE ZERO ZERO FOUR TWO AND I'M
CALLING TODAY TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIXTY ONE.
YEAH THANK YOU. IF THERE ARE
OTHERS WHO LOOK TO STATE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE FIVE NINE
WE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT AB
FIVE FIVE NINE. I DO HAVE ONE
LINE IN Q. WOULD BE JUST MULLIN
THE STRUCTURE. I HAVE A I HAVE
ONE OF THE WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE JOHN SHELTON YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS JOHN SHELTON
EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY- AS
THAT STATE AGENCIES STATE
EMPLOYING WE ARE NEITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BAND- I DID LET A DOCTOR
ARAMBULA STAFF WILL KNOW THAT.
I WAS GOING TO CALL AND CAN'T
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THEY
NEED TO COMMEND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE
OPERATIONS OF THE CONSERVANCY.
AND ARE BORN. THANK YOU I HAVE
ANOTHER LINE IN SUPPORT HOWEVER
AS WITH AN OPERATOR JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. THIS YEAH THAT'S
ONE OF. YEAH WILL MOVE THE LINE
TO FIFTY FOUR TWO FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
SHERIN WEAVER AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER PARKWAY IN CONSERVATION
TRUST AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE FIVE NINE. NORTHERN
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. MURDER MODERATOR WE
PLEASE MOVE OVER TO OPPOSITION
OF THE AUTHORS BILL PLEASE.
THANK YOU TO STATE A POSITION
OF OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE FIVE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN THAT OPPOSITION TO FIVE
FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF NUMBER TWO
FIFTY FIVE TWO FIVE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THIS IS PAUL THE
OTHER ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
JUST EMERGING FRESNO AND MADERA
COUNTIES FOR THE REASONS STATED
IN YOUR ANALYSIS THEY ARE BOTH
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. WE OF
COURSE- IF WE CAN WORK THINGS
OUT WITH THE AUTHORED THE MOST
IN THE PROCESS WE OF COURSE
WILL DO THAT. VERDURE I BOTH
THOUGH TODAY THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR. SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO A- NEW ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. MISTER BIGELOW. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- THE
QUESTIONS OF THE AWESOME
AUTHOR- RECOGNIZING THAT THIS-
CONSERVANCY A 100% IS IT MY
DISTRICT AND IT'S A 100% AND-
MISTER PATTERSON'S WE DIVIDED
FIFTY FIFTY ACTUALLY BUT IT
ISN'T IN YOUR DISTRICT IS THAT
CORRECT. IT IS A REGIONAL
BENEFITS TO THE ENTIRE PARK BUT
YOUR SPECIFICS WERE CORRECT SIR.
AREN'T THERE ENOUGH BUT NONE
THE LESS NEITHER ONE OF US WERE
CONTACTED AND- CONSULTED ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO WORK WITH
THIS PARTICULAR BILL SO THAT
IMPLIES WE'RE A STRONG PART OF
MY OPPOSITION IS. BUT THREE THE
OTHER PART OF MY OPPOSITION FOR
EVERYONE HERE IS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THIS PARTICULAR
CONSERVANCY WAS CREATED. TO BE
OF A REGIONAL BENEFIT IN
BETWEEN FRESNO MADERA COUNTY
YORTY HER TESTIMONY BOTH FRESNO
MADERA COUNTY OR NOT OPPOSITION.
HENCE HERE WE HAVE A CHANGE OF
DIRECTION. AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
THE DIRECTION OF THIS
CONSERVANCY WAS TO BE BALANCED
UNDER LOCAL CONTROL AND NOW
WE'RE MOVING IT AWAY FROM LOCAL
CONTROL TO STATE CONTROL. WHEN
YOU HAVE THE TO LOCAL COMMUNITY
SAYING WE'RE NOT SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS. I THINK THAT GIVES US
PAUSE AND RESUME TO TAKE A
POSITION OF NO. SO I AS ONE
WOULD ASK YOU AS RESPECTFULLY%
TO EITHER NOT VOTE. OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR. OR VOTE
NO I RESPECT FOR ME. THE CHOICE
IS YOURS. NOPE NO DISRESPECT TO
THE AUTHOR IN OUR GOOD FRIENDS.
BUT IT IS A TOUGH ISSUE. SO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MISTER BIGELOW ANY OTHER MR
SALAS AND WILL GO TO MISTER
REYNOLDS. MISTER SELF THANK YOU
MISTER REGISTERED A QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR ON THE- LOCAL
SUPPORT DO YOU HAVE. ARE THERE
ANY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ALL
CALORIES ARE IN SUPPORT OF- THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU SIR- WE HAVE
RECENT DEVELOPMENTS WITHIN THE
LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS WE HAVE
BOTH THE CITY OF MADERA AS WELL
AS THE CITY OF FRESNO. WHO HAVE
PASSED RESOLUTIONS IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE FIVE NINE I BELIEVE
THAT EACH OF THE OFFICES HERE
SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED THOSE
RESOLUTIONS IN SUPPORT. AND
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE STANDING
UP FOR THE PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY SPEAKING LOUDLY ABOUT
THE NEED FOR AB FIVE FIVE NINE.
THANK INCLUDE YOUR QUESTIONS
MISTER CELLS MISTER RAMOS.
THANK UP THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
DOES THIS- ALSO INCLUDE THE
PARTICIPATION OF LOCAL AREA
TRIBES IN THIS- ENDEAVOR MOVING
FORWARD. WELL WE HAVE NOT
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED THE
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS OR- NATIVE
AMERICAN. GROUPS WHO WE WILL
PASS PIC WE ARE LEAVING THAT UP
TO THE LOCALS THERE ARE MANY
TRIBAL NATIONS IN MY COMMUNITY
FOR US TO CHOOSE BETWEEN JUST
TO GIVE YOU A FEW EXAMPLES WE
HAVE THE TABLE MOUNTAIN
RANCHERIA AT THE BIG SANDY
RANCHERIA AND THE COLD SPRINGS
RANCHERIA WITHIN FRESNO COUNTY.
AND MADERA COUNTY WE HAVE THE
NORTH FORK RANCHERIA AND THE
PICK A YUN RANCHERIA OF THE TWO
CHANCY TRIBE AS WELL. THANK YOU
AND INTO THE AUTHOR AGAIN AND
TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN
INCLUDING- THE LOCAL TRAVEL
REPRESENTATIVES IN THIS THESE
TYPES OF ACTIONS IT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE IT IS BUT IT REALLY
SPEAKS TO MANY OF US ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THE ORIGINAL STEWARDS
OF OUR LANDS TO HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. TO MAKE SURE THEY
CAN PARTICIPATE AND CREATE THE
CONSERVATION AND SUSTAINABILITY
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE OF THE
AUTHOR. ME JUST A QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR COULD YOU GIVE ME
THE REASON WHY YOU DIDN'T GO ON
TO CEMENT PATTERSON AND ARE
THERE SOME MEMBER CONSIDERING
THIS IS THEIR DISTRICT A TO ASK
YOU KNOW IS IT WHERE THEY STOOD
AND MAYBE IT WAS SOMETHING THAT
WAS BENEFICIAL PERHAPS IT WOULD
EVEN CALL AUTHORED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND- JUST FOR
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE THIS IS
MY FOURTH YEAR INTRODUCING A
BILL TO WORK ONTHE
CONSERVANCY. AND THE LAST
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE THE BILL WAS
ALSO NUMBERED AB FIVE FIVE
NINE. AND SO JUST FOR
COMPARISON I WILL SAY THIS HAS
BEEN A TOPIC IN AN AREA OF
FOCUS FOR MY OFFICE. FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. MR COOLEY
MINISTER MATHIS. SO REMEMBER
ARAMBULA I JUST WANT TO ASK I'M
A FORMER OFFICER STATEWIDE OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
AND- THE QUESTION IS WHERE IS
THE- WHERE IS HE MAYOR FRESNO
ON THIS JUST FOR THE RECORD HE
SAID THE CITY FRESNO IS A
SUPPORT. BUT HISTORICALLY I
THINK THAT'S A MORE OF A STRONG
MAYOR JURISDICTION- AND I HEARD
WHERE THE MAYOR MATERIALS WE
USE COMMON UPON THAT. GREAT
QUESTION WE HAVE NOT ASKED FOR
THE OPINION CURRENTLY OF THE
MAYOR OF FRESNO. I WILL SHARE
THAT THE RESOLUTION WHICH
PASSED THE PRESENCE CITY
COUNCIL TODAY HAD SIX OF THE
SEVEN MEMBERS VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF. MISTER MATHIS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- QUESTION G.
OPERATE I KNOW WE DISCUSSED IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE ABOUT WHY-
YOU'VE DECIDED TO HAVE THE NEW
APPOINTEES BE BE GIVEN FROM A
STATE LEVEL VERSUS FROM A LOCAL
LEVEL- I HAVE. A I HAVEN'T SEEN
THAT YOU'VE CHANGED THAT- MY
BIGGEST CONCERN IS ENSURING
THAT AS WE'RE DOING THESE
CONSERVANCIES WE KEEP TO THE
LOCAL CONTROL AND AS I SAID
BEFORE. ALLOWING A POSITION FOR
TRAVEL SUPPORT ALLOWING THESE
OTHER POSITIONS I DO SEE AS
IMPORTANT TOOLS. IN OUR
IMPORTANT VOICES TO HAVE BUT I
DO HAVE THAT LARGE CONCERN
ABOUT IT NOT COMING FROM THAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. AND I
KNOW- THROUGH SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF YOUR
OPPOSITION THEY DO SHARE THAT
SAME OPINION SO WHY IS IT YOU
FEEL SO INCLINED. TO NOT SET IT
UP IN SUCH A WAY WITH THE LOCAL
CONTROL CAN PICK THOSE PEOPLE
VERSUS GIVING IT. TO SOMEBODY
WHO'S OVER TWO HUNDRED MILES
AWAY- THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND JUST TO PROVIDE
CLARIFICATION I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TWO APPOINTMENTS
WE ARE SPEAKING ABOUT WILL BE
RESIDENTS OF. FRESNO OR MADERA
COUNTIES. WHILE THOSE
APPOINTMENTS MAY COME HERE AND
SACRAMENTO IF THE LOCALS ARE
UNABLE TO GAIN CONSENSUS AT THE
END OF THE DAY THOSE WILL BE
PEOPLE FROM OUR COMMUNITY WHO
ARE HELPING TO MAKE DECISIONS
AND IMPROVEMENTS ABOUT HOW WE-
MAKE THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER A
BETTER PLACE. GEN JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION CHAIRMAN SO. THE
THERE'S A TERM FOR THAT THOUGH
AND IT'S CALLED CARPETBAGGERS
JUST BECAUSE THEY LIVE THERE
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THEY'RE FROM THERE SO LET'S
KEEP THAT IN MIND SIR I THINK
MANY OF THE TRIBAL NATIONS
WOULD TAKE OFFENSE TO BEING
CALLED CARPETBAGGERS THIS WAS
THEIR LANDS LONG BEFORE MANY OF
US CAME TO THE STATE. WELL AS
I'M TALKING ABOUT ADDING A SEAT
FOR TRIBAL NATIONS I JUST
THERE'S TREMENDOUS. CAREFUL
ABOUT THE WORDS WE USE. YOU
HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU MISTER
MATHIS- NOT WE DON'T NEED A
DIALOGUE WITH DO YOU HAVE ANY
MORE CALL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
USING. THANK YOU SIR. HOW CAN I
HELP. WHAT BEST DECISION THE
NEW. MMHM MISTER BIGELOW WOULD
LIKE TO ASK ANOTHER QUESTION I.
FOR MEDICAL. JUST A SIMPLE
COMMENT I DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR ON THIS AND IT IS A
DIFFICULT POSITION I WANT TO
REMEMBER TO KNOW. TO GET A
LANDOWNER TO COMMIT TO THE TIME
IT TAKES TO BEING ON THE
CONSERVANCY IS A HUGE
UNDERTAKING AT THE SAME TIME
THERE ARE VERY FEW. PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS THAT ACTUALLY ON
LAND WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES
WITHIN THE CONSERVANCY THAT'S
THE PLACE WHERE THE LANDOWNER
GETS TO COME FROM IN BE CHOSEN
FROM THE POOL OF NOMINEES TO BE
REPRESENTED. I DO SUPPORT THE
POSITION OF HAVING A TRIBAL
ENTITY APPOINTED TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR REPRESENTATION
THAT HAS LONG BEEN SOMETHING
THAT'S OVERDUE. AND HE DOES.
ACCURATELY STATE ALTHOUGH THERE
IS ONE THAT I'VE HIGH JUST FOR
TRIVIA FOR EVERYONE. THERE IS A
TRIBAL. IN EIGHTY THAT EXISTS
TO THE DOGMA TRIED. AND THERE'S
ONLY ONE LIVING MEMBER LEFT OF
THAT FIVE ALONG THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER. BUT THERE ARE MANY
TRIBES. THAT HAVE USE THAT AREA
AS PART OF THEIR REGIONAL AND
HOMELAND AREAS OF HISTORIC AND-
RECORD. SO I WANT TO BE FAIR TO
THE TO THE AUTHOR OF THIS LIKE
I SAID BEFORE WE'RE FRIENDS WE
JUST HAVE A LITTLE SLIGHT.
SIDEWAYS DISAGREEMENT HERE BUT
I REALLY THINK THAT WE NEED TO
THINK THIS THROUGH BEFORE WE
MOVE. THE WEIGHTED VALUE AWAY
FROM THE LOCAL. TO THE STATE
BUT I DO APPRECIATE HIM WANTING
TO MAKE THIS ADDITION. OF THE
TRIBAL FOLKS AND I WANT TO GET
THE CLARIFICATION THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR FOR ALLOWING ME TO
DO THAT. WITH THAT DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. FOR THE OFFERS THE.
SAWSAN VERSUS IN A SECOND
AMERICA- CURRENTLY YOUR CURRENT-
MISTER SINISTER A REGULAR. I
REMEMBER GROWING UP IN BEING A
FRIEND AND- STONE UP AND DOWN
THE RIVER. IT'S GORGEOUS AREA.
I APPRECIATE CONSERVANCY'S
EFFORTS FOR THIS YOU KNOW AFTER
THE REGULAR CHANNELS. ACTUALLY
INSTALLED THE SECOND SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER WAS HAS DRIED UP
FOR PARAMEDIC SIXTY SOMETHING
MILES- I'M HOPING THE
CONSERVANCY CAN BRING THAT BACK
TO LIFE AT SOME POINT IN TIME
WITH THEIR EFFORTS. AND I THINK
IT TAKES MORE THAN JUST A LOCAL
EFFORT TO DO SOMETIMES. GOT TO
WORK. SO OTHER THAN I FIRST
TIME I'VE HEARD TODAY ABOUT MR
BIG WAS CONCERNS. NO I'M
SUPPORTING THIS BILL ON THE ON
THE MERITS THAT YOU'VE STATED
BUT ALSO INSIST THAT YOU WORK
WITH MR PATTERSON AND MR.
BIGELOW GOING FORWARD BECAUSE I
DO RESPECT MR BIGELOW AND HIS
OPINION. I DON'T WANT TO FIGHT
BUT I ALSO WANT TO INSIS THAT
YOU HAVE A COLLABORATION. WHERE
IT IS A REGIONAL APPROACH AND
IT DOES. WORK WITH MR BIGELOW
AS A FORMER SUPERVISOR IN THAT
AREA. WAS VERY FINIT KNOWLEDGE
OF THE AREA. I WANT THAT. TO BE
PART OF THE EQUATION. SO WITH
THAT COMMITMENT FROM YOU AGAIN
I DO HAVE A DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDED THAT
SECRETARIES PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM ONE AB FIVE
FIVE NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER HI BIGELOW NO BIGELOW
NOW AGUIAR-CURRY. I BERMAN.
CORREO COOLEY. COOPER DALY DALY
AYE DAVIES DAVIES NO GALLAGHER.
GARCIA GARCIA AYE GIPSON. JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY NO MATHIS
MATHIS NO QUICK SILVA. RAMOS
RAMOS I REQUEST RIVAS HI RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH.
SMITH KNOWN VIA PUT WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO I. I HAVE A NINE IT.
THIS REVENUE THE BILL HAS NINE
TO LEAD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO. AB FOUR FORTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF OUR CON. SO YOU
PACING BACK THERE DILIGENTLY.
VERY COLD I WAS TRYING TO STAY
WARM MISTER CHAIR. LET ME DO A
LITTLE BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING
RGHT OKAY I DON'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT YOU HAVE PAID. FOR
THE MAIN WITNESSES ONLY THE
NUMBER IS HAS CHANGED PLEASE
USE EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT TWO FOUR
ZERO. SEVEN EIGHT TWO EIGHT
THAT'S. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT TWO
FOUR ZERO. SEVEN EIGHT TWO
EIGHT. WITH THE PASSCODE THAT
PREVIOUSLY WERE USED. SO WE'LL
JUST GET RID OF THAT
HOUSEKEEPING RIGHT NOW TO GET A
PART APOLOGIZE FOR THE
INTERRUPTION PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
TODAY PRESENT AT TWELVE FORTY
TWO A BILL THAT CODIFIES THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
ALLOWING LACES RESTAURANTS TO
CONTINUE SELLING MAKE UP A
HOLIDAY DRINKS TO GO. THE
COMBINED EFFECT THE NECESSARY.
LOCKDOWNS IN THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. THAT I HAVE DAVIS THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. NATIONALLY
A HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
RESTAURANTS HAVE SHUTTERED IN
TWO AND A HALF MILLION JOBS
HAVE BEEN LOST. THESE ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES FAMILY BUSINESSES
PILLARS OF COMMUNITY AND BAD
ROCKS OF FINANCIAL SECURITY FOR
SO MANY. DURING THE PANDEMIC
MOST BARS AND RESTAURANTS
RELYING ON THE LIFELINE OF TAKE
OUT BUSINESS. RECOGNIZING THIS
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
GOVERNOR ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER DIRECTING CALIFORNIA
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL TO
TEMPORARILY LIFT ITS REGULATION
THAT HAD BARRED TO GO ALCOHOL
WOULD TAKE OUT MEALS. THIS IS A
CRUCIAL BURNED TO RESTAURANTS
AND BARS AS WELL AS WE NEED
SAFETY MEASURE WILL INDOOR
DINING ROOMMATE ARREST. WITH
TAKE OUT WINE AND BEER ALREADY
LEGAL TAKE OUT PRACTICES ARE
COMMON SENSE AND PROFITABLE
VENTURE HOWEVER AFTER THE
PANDEMIC SUCH SALES WILL LIKELY
BE PROHIBITED ONCE AGAIN. THIS
PANDEMIC YOU'RE A COCKTAIL
DELIVERY SHOWN THAT SUCH A
PROHIBITION IS UNNECESSARY. FOR
YEARS PEOPLE HAVE ORDERED
PICKED UP AND ENJOYED MIXED
DRINKS FROM THEIR FAVORITE
RESTAURANTS AS PART OF A SAFE
DINING EXPERIENCE. BUSINESSES
HAVE BEEN SAVED BY THIS INCOME
WITH RESTAURANTS WHO SOLD
ALCOHOL HAVING BEEN MORE LIKELY
TO RE HIRE STAFF DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AB TWELVE FORTY TO
MAKE PERMANENT THE ABC
ALLOWANCE FOR TAKE OUT
COCKTAILS WITH FOOD. FOOD
BUSINESSES ALREADY LICENSED TO
SELL ALCOHOL ON THE PREMISES
WOULD BE ABLE TO SELL COCKTAILS
COCKTAILS IN SECURE CONTAINERS
FOR TAKEOUT AND DELIVERY. I'VE
HEARD THE CONCERNS FROM THE
ANTI ALCOHOL GROUPS AND
ALLOWING THESE DRINKS TO BE
TRANSPORTED THERE FOR OF
AMENDED THE BILL TO ADDRESS
THIS CONCERN IN THE FOLLOWING
WAYS. I ADDED TO YOUR SENSE ON
THE BILL FROM THE DATE WHEN THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY IS LIFTED SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE. THAT THIS
IS BEING DONE SAFELY. WE ALSO
REQUIRED THAT IT CAN. LATE OR
CO THE EFFECTS TO THE CAN IN A
MANNER THAT MAKES IT OBVIOUS.
WHEN I CAP. LATE OR SEAL THE
BEEN REMOVED OR BROKEN. AND IT
LIMITS THE DRINKS TO PER MAIL.
WITH ME TODAY. TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE FORTY
TWO IS NOT SET IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. AND LARA MAGU WITH
THE REV BISTRO IN LAFAYETTE. SO
LET'S MOVE FORWARD HERE
WITNESSES MODERATE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MET CERTAIN
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WHAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS A POLICY
THAT'S BEEN TESTED IT'S BEEN IN
PLACE FOR A YEAR- UNDER THE ABC
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS LAST
MARCH AT THE OUTSET AND
PANDEMIC THESE WERE PUT IN
PLACE WHEN RESTAURANTS AT THE
TIME WERE ORDERED- TO CEASE ALL
INDOOR DINING IN ONLY DO
DELIVERY AND TAKEOUT. WE'VE HAD
A YEAR OF OSCILLATING ON AGAIN
OFF AGAIN INDOOR DINING ONLY
OUTDOOR DINING TAKEOUT DELIVERY
NOT TKE OUT DELIVERY BACK AND
FORTH BACK AND FORTH WHAT THIS
DOES IS THIS HELPS HELPS GET
THROUGH THAT PERIOD BUT IT ALSO
LOOKS TO THE FUTURE AND HELPS
MODERNIZE ALCOHOL LAWS WITH
SAFETY PROTECTIONS IN PLACE. TO
HELP ACCOMMODATE WHAT HAVE
BECOME CHANGE CONSUMER DEMANDS
AND- THE ABILITY FOR
RESTAURANTS TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE ALCOHOL IN A SAFE WAY-
WITH MEALS- GOING OUT THE DOOR-
AS WAS MENTIONED THERE'S A
NUMBER OF PROTECTIVE PROTOCOLS
PUT IN PLACE THE EMERGENCY
REGULATION BUT ALSO IN THIS
LEGISLATION AS WELL THOSE
REGULATE EXACTLY HOW THE
BEVERAGES LEAVE A RESTAURANT.
AND PROVIDE FOR SAFE TRANSPORT
OF THOSE TO A CONSUMER- SO WE
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND
BELIEVE THAT THE STRIKES ARE
REALLY GOOD BALANCE OF
CONTINUING WHAT HAS BEEN A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. THANK THANK
YOU MOVE ON OUR MODERATOR.
MODERATOR LAURA MAGOON. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR NUMBER MY NAME IS
LAURA MCGILL AND I NEED OWNER
AND OPERATOR OF WEB BISTRO-
READ THE FULL SERVICE
RESTAURANTS IN LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA. I'M AT THE POINT OF
AB TWELVE FORTY TWO AND WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY ONE OF OUR QUE
HAN FOR HER THOUGHTFUL APPROACH
TO THIS ISSUE. IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY WHAT EVERYONE
THOUGHT AND IT HAD TO DO BUT
THE AND YOU WEEKS OF RESTAURANT
CLOSURES. IN THE OVER A YEAR OF
ON AGAIN OFF AGAIN OPENING AND
CLOSING THAT DEVASTATED. MANY
IN MY RESTAURANT COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE LIKE ME AND MY HOW TO
OUR WRAPPED. AND THERE WERE A
LOT OF. THAT NEVER EIGHT OUT.
SO WITHIN FORTY EIGHT HOURS WE
WERE REQUIRED TO TOTALLY PINNED
IT. CHANGE OUR BUSINESS MODEL
AND CREATE A WHOLE NEW.
BUSINESSES IN JUST FORTY EIGHT
HOURS TO SAVE OUR FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESS. EIGHTY TWO FORTY TWO
SO TAKE HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR
OVER A YEAR. AND SEEKS TO MAKE
IT OUT BACK THE PANDEMIC BY
ALIGNING CALIFORNIA WITH A
GROWING NUMBER OF STATES THAT
ALLOW RESTAURANTS TO SELL
ALCOHOL FOR TAKEOUT. AND
DELIVERY. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER MY SUPPORT FOR CONTINUING
THE PROGRAM FOR THE COMING
FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE OVER
TO THE- CHAMBERS ANYBODY THE
CHAMBER TO SUPPORT THE BILL OF
THE AUTHOR SEEING NINE. THOSE
IN THE CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK TO THE BILL. SEEING NONE
AS WE KNOW THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM IS DOWN TODAY.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO THE PHONES
MODERATOR FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
EVERYONE. MR IF YOU WANT TO
STATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE
FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT AB.
ONE TWO FOUR TWO. WE DO HAVE A
FEW LINES IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES
IN LINE TO NINETY TWO TWO NINE
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THAT A
NUMBER THAT THEY WITH THAT
INDEPENDENT HOSPITALITY
COALITION ATTEMPTING
INDEPENDENT BOX OFFICE ON IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT AT
TWELVE TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM
MINE TO SEVENTY FOUR TWO SEVEN
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT
AFTERNOON BALLERINA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE.
THANK YOU. OVER THE LINE THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
MODERATOR WE OPEN THE LINES
FOR- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
CERTAINLY TO STATE YOUR
POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE TWO OR TO
IMPRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I HAVE SEVERAL NINETY OPERATORS
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
WELL FIRST A LINE OF. TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR TWO SEVEN
FOUR. AMONG OUR ONLINE
DISCONNECTED JUST AS I OPEN
BELOW THE LINE TWO SEVEN NINE
TWO SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SEVENTY NINE OPPOSITION
THE STATE YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS MARY BETH I'M
CALLING OUT THE REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL
POLICY OF MINE AND WE ARE
SUPPOSED FROM THE POST AB
TWELVE FORTY TWO BECAUSE THE
BANK CAME ABILITY OF ALCOHOL- I
KNOW NUMBER OF PATIENTS PUBLIC
SPACES AND EXPECT EXTENSIVELY
DURING PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
WE- DO NOT NEED MORE MODERNIZE
ALCOHOL LAWS WE DO NOT HAVE.
THE SAFETY MEASURES AND NO REAL
WAY TO ENSURE THAT THESE
REGULATIONS THAT ARE BEING
MENTIONED WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
WE MUST ASSUME THAT THE AVP I
WILL NOT ENGAGE IN AND PARTLY
BECAUSE MOST OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT REALLY
ENFORCEABLE WHEN YOU HAVE A
CRITICAL LOOK AT HOW. FOR THE
COMPROMISE OUR COMMUNITIES
ALREADY SUFFERING FROM
SUBSTANCE ABUSE- PERPETUATING
DRUG DRIVING ENACTED THERE IS A
CRITICAL CONVERSATION ABOUT
HEARTBEAT ACTOR TO POINT GOING
TO COMPROMISE EXISTING WITH
ACTED TO ALCOHOL WE CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT BUSINESS THOSE
AREN'T TALKING ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS AND
THE REGULATE READ REGULATION
MEASURES LIKE YOU BEING
MENTIONED THEY'RE NOT TRUE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER THEY
NEED ANY. ACTUAL EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION- OF AND
COMPLIANCE- YOU COURAGE AND
STRONG NO WELL AB. TWELVE FORTY
TWO THANK YOU. IF YOU.
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANYBODY
WELCOME VISITOR ELSE IN THE- WE
DO HAVE TO MORE LINE IN QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION. WHAT WILL GO TO
TWO SIX TWO SEVENTY SIX SEVEN.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S MICHAEL
REPRESENTING ALCOHOL JEFF- WE
OPPOSE AB TWELVE FORTY TWO-
EVER SINCE- THE LINK DEATH AND
INJURY FROM AND DRIVING BECAME
EVIDENT COCKTAILS TO GO I'VE
BEEN PROHIBITED IN THE STATE-
THEY ARE NEVER A GOOD IDEA. AND
THEY SHOULD NEVER BECOME
PERMANENT PRIVILEGE. AND IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KEEP ON SALE AND
ALL SALES SEPARATE- TO PROTECT
OUR HIGHWAYS FROM PEOPLE
DRINKING ON THEIR WAY HOME. AND
TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF OPEN
CONTAINERS THAT WILL SHOW UP IN
PUBLIC SPACES. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FROM THIS POINT
FORWARD THAT'S THE TWO
WITNESSES IN THE IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
TAKE YOUR NAME WE REPRESENTING
AND HOW YOU AND YOUR OPPOSITION
PLEASE. MORRELL NEXT LINE IS
TWO FIVE SEVEN TO FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CARE
MEMBERS SPREAD JONES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON ALCOHOL PROBLEMS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. LINE. TWO FIFTY
NINE TWO FIVE NINE. HELLO
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STEVEN
UPDATE I AM A MEMBER OF BURGLAR
PROTECT ENTRY CAN CENTER HOUSES
M. OPPOSED TO AB TWELVE FORTY
TWO WE ARE NOT ANTI ALCOHOL WE
ARE INTO A PUBLIC HARM FROM
ALCOHOL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NO FOR LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR. ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR. SEEING NONE THE. DO
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON YOUR BILL
RESPECT THAT AND I THINK IF
YOU'RE TWENTY OR SECOND ON THIS
BILL. THE MISTER MATHIS
SAMANTHA. WILL THINK. THE
SECOND MISTRESS STRAIGHT.
YOU'RE SO- SO I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU. AGAIN IN THESE
UNCERTAIN TIMES STANDING UP FOR
BUSINESSES- YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE
WHAT WE COULD IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT RECOGNIZING
THAT WE CAN DO MORE TO STATUES
IS EXCEPTIONAL AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE AS A FORMER BUSINESS
OWNER. KNOWING THAT THERE'S
SOMEBODY OUT THERE REALLY DOES
CARE ABOUT SUCCESS. WITH THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM TO AB TWELVE
FORTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW
HI BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN BERMAN
I GOT REAL. CORREO I COOLEY
COOLEY AYE COOPER- COOPER AYE
DALY DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I'D
GALLAGHER GARCIA. GARCIA AYE
GIPSON- GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY WHO LIKE IN OUR VOTING
MATHIS. MATHIS HI MARK SILVA
RICK SILVA I'D ALMOST RAMOS I
AM RIVAS. RIVAS HI RUBIO. RUBIO
AYE SALAS. SALAS I SMITH. SMITH
I'D BE ABLE TO A BE A GOODBYE.
NINETEEN THE BILL HAS NINETEEN
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU. STICK
AROUND KID HOW. SO WE'RE GONNA
DO A LITTLE BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING
THE ONE MR CUTTING HIM COME UP
I WANT OPEN THE ROLE FOR- AB
FIVE FIVE NINE. SECRETARY
POWELL. FILE ITEM ONE AB FIVE
FIVE NINE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN. BERMAN
I'VE GOT REAL. CORREO HI COOLEY.
COOPER. GIPSON JONES SAWYER.
QUICK SILVA. CORRECT SILVA HI.
THE BILLS OUT HAS TWELVE
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. SO WHEN YOU'RE
READY THERE IS. MISTER K. YEAH
MR CELLS WE WILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN I
WANT TO START BY THINKING THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE- SEVEN
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
DISCUSSED WITH COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AS AMENDED TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN WILL CLARIFY THAT
AN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURER CAN ADVERTISE AND
DONATE A PORTION THE PROCEEDS
OF THE SALE. OF AN ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE TO A NONPROFIT
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATION. THESE
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE TERRIBLE
PROMOTIONS EXISTS TODAY UNDER
TEMPORARY CODE RULES AND TODAY
BC- YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THEM AT
YOUR LOCAL GROCERY STORE. MIGHT
BE ADVERTISING THAT A PORTION
OF THE PROCEEDS OF SALE WOULD
GO TO BENEFIT WILDFIRE RECOVERY
COVERT NINETEEN RECOVERY OCEAN
CLEANUP ANIMAL SHELTERS US
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS. FOOD
BANKS AND A HOST OF OTHER
WORTHY CAUSES WERE SEEKING TO
CODIFY THIS TEMPORARY RULE I
THINK THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY
COUNT ON PROFITS IN THE WINE
INSTITUTE WITH ME TODAY. WITH
THE WINE INSTITUTE'S TYLER
BLACKPINK TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE THAT I AM UNABLE TO
ANSWER. MISTER CUNNINGHAM I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A WITNESS ON
THE PHONE TYLER BLACK THE FOR
THE WIN INSTITUTE. YES MISTER
CHAIR MISTER MODERATE OPEN THE
LINE YET. YES YOU CAN HEAR ME
MR YES. I GET AFTERNOON CARE
NUMBERS TODD LIKE MAYBE
HAPPENED ONE INSTITUTE- YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
ISSUE- COMPANY WINERIES ARE
DEEPLY INVESTED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND GET A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT THROUGH
DONATIONS TO VARIOUS NONPROFIT-
IS WANTS TO DUSTIN IS THAT WHEN
YOU GET BACK APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUAL CHARITY. AND YES SOME OF
THESE TERRIBLE GIVING'S TAKES
THE FORM OF A TERRIBLE
PROMOTION WHEREBY IN THE NATION
MADE A CONNECTION THE SALE OF A
BOTTLE OF WINE- AT THE OFFICE
RECENTLY TO OUR KNOWLEDGE-
UNLAWFUL BY THE CALIFORNIA
RECALL NEVER CONTROL- WELL WE
DISAGREE WITH THE V. P.
INTERPRETATION WE DO FEAR THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES IF THIS
WERE TO BECOME. ENFORCEMENT
PRIORITY- BECAUSE OF THIS WE
FEEL AB TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN IT'S
NECESSARY TO CLARIFY THE LAW TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THESE TYPES OF
MOTIONS ARE ALLOWED AND I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE A POINT MADE BY
THE AUTHOR THAT OVER THE PAST
YEAR EDT HAVE BEEN ALLOWING
THESE TYPES OF DONATIONS FOR
KOBE NINETEEN RELATED
CHARITIES- WITH NO REPORTED
ISSUES THAT WE KNOW OF-
DISCUSSED AMENDMENTS LIKE THE
OTHERS AGREED TO TAKE WILL
MIRROR THE BILL TO ABC'S
CURRENT PARAMETERS FOR MAKING
PROMOTIONAL DONATIONS- JUST.
THEY WILL PLAY AT ALL OR THE
CHARITY OF NOT JUST THE
SPECIFIC OF THE NINETEEN- FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT AB
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN AND ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE- AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER.
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
SO WE'RE GONNA ON TO. ANY OF
THE IN THE CHAIN THAT WOULD TO
SEE SPEAKERS. THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE AS SEEN IN THE OF.
WOULD LIKE TO IN UP TO THE US
BILL. SEEING NONE. OF THESE AS
WE STATED THE VIDEO FOR DOWN.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONES- MODERATOR FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
TO SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT. ME JUST A MOMENT FOR
THE OTHERS TO HAVE THEIR LINE
NUMBERS PROVIDE. TWO SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY TO SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MAYOR
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE NOT
COMPLY ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
WINEMAKERS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT IN HERE THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ONE MORE LINE NUMBER TO BE
GATHERED ONE MOMENT. NINE TO
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETEEN FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE SOUTH PEOPLE CARTER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN Q. THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE M. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON THE LINER IN THE
QUEUE OF MODERATOR FOR
OPPOSITION THE AUTHORS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. STE INTERESTED SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL SKIP
ON BEHALF OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE.
WE LOOK AT THIS BILL AS ANOTHER
FORM OF MARKETING MASQUERADING
AS FULL ANSWER PEAK. NON
PROFITS- STRAPPED FOR OPERATING
REVENUE ARE AN EASY MARK FOR
EXPLOITATION HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
THE RELATIONSHIP IS TOXIC AT
ITS CORE. THE JUNE TENTH OF THE
GIFT IN ITS PROMOTION IS TO
STIMULATE GREATER CONSUMPTION
WHICH INEVITABLY LEADS TO
INCREASED ALCOHOL RELATED HARM.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
INDUSTRY TARGETS THEM FOR JUST
THIS PURPOSE. IN LIEU OF THE
NONPROFIT AND LIGHTENED I GET
ACCEPT POLICY TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND DISSUADE THIS
CREATOR WE BELIEVE THE CURRENT
PROHIBITION SHOULD REMAIN IN
EFFECT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NOBLE ON A. B. TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE MARIN.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER CALLERS IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ANY QUESTIONS OF- THE AUTHORED
BY THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM WHICH I
CLOSED THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO BRIEFLY
ADDRESS AN ISSUE RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION- FIRST OF ALL THE
WINE INDUSTRY. DONATES A
HUNDRED ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY ALREADY- TO CHARITY SO
I DON'T THINK IT'S A FICTION
BUT THERE'S CONSIDERABLE
GENERASI GOING FROM OUR FAMILY
WINEMAKERS SMALL BUSINESS
WINEMAKERS ANOTHER ONE MAKERS
TOWARDS CHARITABLE CAUSES
ALREADY AND WE'VE ALREADY HAD
SORT OF A PILOT PROGRAM BECAUSE
THIS IS BEEN A PLACE DURING
COVERED WE'VE NOT SEEN ANY- ANY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS OR REALLY
ANY PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE AWARE
OF- I THINK THIS IS GOOD FOR
CHARITY IT'S GOOD FOR. OUR
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE HAD SOME TOUGH TIMES AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU TO HAVE A FIRST OR SECOND
FOR THE OFFICE BILL. MISTER
MATHIS MISTER DAVIS. WE HAVE
THE FIRST THE SECOND- MISTER
CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR AGAIN JUST LIKE OUR
PREVIOUS AUTHOR. RECOGNIZING
THAT ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
AS YOU LIKE KNOWLEDGE. IT'S NOT
THAT HASN'T BEEN UNPRECEDENTED
ALREADY JUST A DIFFERENT CARRY
OUT OF A WAY OF SUPPORTING. THE
PEOPLE OUR COMMUNITY THAT
ACTUALLY DOING THINGS THAT
GOVERNMENT CAN'T DO AND SO I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU
STEPPING UP AND DOING THAT I'M
SORRY PLEASE CALL. FILE ITEM
FOR AB TWO TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW
AYE BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN. CORREO
CARRILLO AYE COOLEY COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER AYE DALY. DALY
AYE DAVIES. DAVIS AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE GIPSON- GIPSON I
JONES SAWYER. LACKING LACKEY I
MATHIS MATHIS AYE PORK SILVA.
BURKE SURVIVOR MOST RAMOS I
RIVAS RIVAS I RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SALAS. SALAS I SMITH SMITH I'D
BE ABLE TO A- BE A GOODBYE.
THIS IS NINETEEN OR TWENTY. THE
BILL HAS NINETEEN VOTES IS THAT
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SIXTY ONE
MISTER GABRIEL. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OVER
THE PAST YEAR ALL OF US HAVE
WALKED AS SMALL BUSINESSES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT SINCE
LAST APRIL CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS HAVE LOST
APPROXIMATELY. SIX POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN SALES. AND
OVER ONE MILLION EMPLOYEES HAVE
BEEN FURLOUGHED OR LAID OFF.
79% OF RESTAURANT OWNERS DO NOT
EXPECT TO TURN A PROFIT IN THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS. THESE
NEIGHBORHOOD RESTAURANTS ARE
THE BACKBONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES
BUT TO MANY ARE HANGING ON BY A
THREAD. DESPITE RECENT PROGRESS
ON VACCINES IT HAS BECOME CLEAR
THAT OUTDOOR DINING WILL BE
DIFFERENT CRITICAL COMPONENT.
OF MANY RESTAURANTS SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM PLANS FOR KEEPING
THEIR DOORS OPEN. AB SIXTY ONE
OFFERS A LIFELINE TO STRUGGLING
NEIGHBORHOOD RESTAURANTS IN THE
FORM OF TEMPORARY REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY. WHICH WILL HELP TO
FACILITATE OUTDOOR DINING AS
WELL AS MORE ROBUST TAKE OUT
AND DELIVERY OPTIONS. IN SOME
THIS BILL OFFERS A TEMPORARY
FLEXIBLE SOLUTION THAT IS VITAL
FOR THE NEIGHBORHOOD-RESTAURANTS THAT CONTRIBUTE SO
MUCH TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AND THE PEOPLE WE SERVE. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL OR MATT SUTTON THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. AMOUNT OF MADELINE
O'CONNOR. THE OWNER OF MARIA'S
ITALIAN KITCHEN ONE OF MY
ABSOLUTE FAVORITE RESTAURANTS
IN THE WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I'VE A- LOOK MOVE
ON THE MISTER SUN. THANK YOU
AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MET
SUDDENLY CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT.
I WILL BE BRIEF AND NOT TO GIVE
MY TWO MINUTES BUT MISTER
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK AND EFFORT ON THIS
BILL IN THE PREVIOUS CALL THAT
WE WERE INTERESTED IN WHAT
YOU'VE DONE IS YOU FOUND A
SWEET SPOT THAT PROTECTS PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND HELPS
RESTAURANTS GET OUT OF THIS.
CURRENT DILEMMA SO THANK YOU
WHAT THE BILL DOES MR GABRIEL
SAID IT IS- IT REALLY TAKES
OUTDOOR DINING WHICH IS BEEN
CRITICAL FOR THE LAST YEAR AND
IS FRANKLY GOING TO BE CRITICAL
GOING FORWARD AND THERE'S A
COUPLE REASONS FOR THAT ONE IS
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
CONTINUE TO WARN ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL OF THE VARIANTS AND
WHAT THEY MAY OR MAY NOT DO.
THAT OF COURSE WILL MATTER AND
DICTATE WHAT LEVEL OF
OPERATIONS WERE ALLOWED TO HAVE
INDOORS SO OUTDOOR DINING HAS
BEEN A LIFELINE THIS BILL TAKE
SOME OF THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THAT A. B. C.
OFFERED WHICH ESSENTIALLY DOES
THIS. FOR THESE NEW AND
REIMAGINED. DINING SPACES THAT
MANY OF YOU HAVE IN YOUR
DISTRICTS IT CREATES AN- OF
TEMPORARY CATERING
AUTHORIZATION WHICH ESSENTIALLY
ALLOWS A STREAMLINED PROCESS.
TO HAVE THESE OUTDOOR DINING
ENVIRONMENTS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THEY'RE ALL OVER
THE STATE THEY'VE GOT LOTS OF
NEAT ENVIRONMENTS IN DIFFERENT
CITIES THAT'S WHAT THIS DOES IT
ALSO ENABLES ALCOHOL TO BE
SERVED AS AN OPTION IN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS. AND IT TAKES CARE
OF A NUMBER OF OTHER PUBLIC
SAFETY PROTECTIONS. AND AGAIN
CREATES VIBRANT COMMUNITIES AND
NEAT OUTDOOR SPACES THE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS LOVE. AND ARE
COMPLETELY SAFE AND WELL
REGULATED SO THANK YOU. CLICK
SERVICE MARIN WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON FOR WHICH IS ON THE PHONE.
MADELINE EL FARO. I'M MY ARM
YES YOU ARE. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS YOUR NUMBER-
I'M THAT'LL HELP ON A PROJECT-
WITH EIGHT LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA
I'M ALSO THE PROUD CHAIRMAN OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION BOARD OF DIRECTORS
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JESSE GAVE THE FOR THAT GREAT
COMPLIMENT BUT ALSO YOUR
LEADERSHIP HERE ARE CONTINUE TO
TURN OBSTACLES INTO
OPPORTUNITIES. REGARDING
RESTAURANT THIS RESPONSE TO
PROVIDE NINETEEN AND CHECKING
TO MAKE THESE POSITIVE CHANGES
LAST YEAR ON THE PANDEMIC OVER
THE LAST YEAR RESTAURANTS THAT
THE TO WEEKLY CHANGES BY STATE
AND LOCAL DIRECTORS REGARDS TO
HOW WE COULD OPERATE A
RESTAURANT IS IT INSIDE OUTSIDE
TAKE OUT DELIVERY ONLY IT WAS
CHALLENGING FOR OWNERS
EMPLOYEES. AND CUSTOMERS. IT
YOUR DINING WITH TO DOWN. AT
THE JEFF FOR THANKS AND-
BECAUSE FOR. AND MONTHS AND
MONTHS THROUGHOUT RESTAURANT
POLITICKING AND- L. A. COUNTY
SHIFT THEIR OVER AND A HALF
MONTHS. YOU TODAY CONTINUE TO
THE RESTRICTED ALL. THE ENDS OF
THE CONTROL. LIMIT AT THAT IS
50% OF IN CAPACITY. WHICH
REALLY IMPORTANT IS. THIS WITH
PHYSICAL. OKAY PLACEMENT FOR ME
AND SMALL. LIKE MINE YOU REALLY
ONLY ALLOW 425% YOU JUST SITE.
OF WHICH. THIS IS WHY OUTDOOR
DINING THE RATE. RELIEF OF A BY
THE SEAT AT THE OUT OF. HAS
BEEN- LIFELINE FOR THE SERVER
CARE CAN. YOU CAN TO ARE MADE
NUMBERS. I KNOW THIS TO BE TRUE
FOR SO MANY REST WERE BY MY-
AND WOMEN TO THIS. IN FACT
PERCENT OF. RUSH ARE OWNED BY
OF. WE ARE. AND WE'RE JUST IN
OUT THAT OUTDOOR JUST OUR
SPIRIT ALIVE. THE FIRST DINING
IS I LIKE TO CALL IT HISTORY
AND HER TRANSFORMED DEPRESSED
NEIGHBORHOOD IN DIVIDE OUT
EATERY. CAFES SEE ALL OF YOUR-
EVEN JUST NOT STEPS TO ALLOW.
AFTER HERE'S TO TREAT AND TO
CREATE IN AND BY ON. THE
CREATURE AND NEVER ABOUT. MAKES
ME PROUD. YOUR OUR CUT. ARE
LOWER FOR THEIR HAVE PLACE FROM
OF THE. RED WITH FAMILY FRIEND.
AB SIXTY ONE BE CREEK AS THE
RESTAURANT RECOVERING HEALTH
WILL TAKE. YEARS A- WE CAN CAN
TO MAKE GOOD POWER. YEAH AND
YOU KNOW OF ALL TO THE-
RESTAURANT. THANK YOU AND I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY AT OF MY- AND- OF
RESTAURANTS OWNERS AND
THEREFORE SPREAD OUT THROUGHOUT
THE OF YOUR- HAVE A GOOD DAY.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. SO I'M
GOING TO ASK THOSE THE CHAMBER.
THERE'S A CHAMBER THAT HAS. SO
OF THE AUTHORS BILL LIKE TO
SPEAK. SAYING NO IN THE IN THE
CHAMBER IN OFFICE TO THE AUTHOR
BILL. SEEING NONE AS I
MENTIONED THE VIDEO CONFERENCE
DOWN. SO MARIO GONNA GO THE
PHONES IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE
GENERAL AT THIS TIME. LINE TWO
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SHALL BE AT
LEAST SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT. AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA ALSO DRUNK THE PARK
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE TO
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARED MEMBERS OF THE MILLION
THE MONEY CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL. AND
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY ONE THANK
YOU. YOU. NINE TO NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CAREY MEMBERS
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK IN
THIS BILL WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RESEARCHER
MEMBERS FOR A JONES ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL MEDICAL
PROBLEMS IN A RARE POSITION OF
SUPPORT WE THINK THIS IS A MORE
APPROPRIATE MEANS OF DELIVERING
ALCOHOL IN THE PRIOR BILL
HEARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR THERE ANY OTHER.
CALLS IN SO YES WE DO HAVE A
FEW MORE OKAY NINE TO NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE HI MY NAME IS HI
MY NAME IS HUNTER FALLEN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ONE OF
THE BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT
DISTRICTS IN SANTA MONICA THAT
WAS THE FIRST TO HAVE. AN
ALFRESCO SET UP AND IT HAS BEEN
AN ABSOLUTE LIFELINE FOR EVERY
BUSINESS IN OUR DISTRICT- I
REALLY CAN'T SAY. ENOUGH ABOUT
THE NECESSITY OF THIS BILL AND
HOW MUCH GOOD IT WILL DO FOR
THE RESTAURANTS STATEWIDE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT CALL PLEASE. NINE TWO
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DONNA
DUPONT TOWARDS AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. NINE TWO
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME EITHER WELL MY WIFE AND I
OWN TWO SMALL NEIGHBORHOOD
RESTAURANTS AND A AN OUTDOOR
COFFEE BAR HERE IN LOS ANGELES
AND- OUR FULL SUPPORT BEHIND
THE BILL WOULD LIFELINE AND-
YEAH. JUST THOROUGHLY INTO THE
CHRIS ALL THE WORK WAS INTO IT
THANK YOU. NINE TWO SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MADE OUT FOR OUR- I
ONLY CAFE IN HIGHLAND PARK AND-
YEAH I THE COMMON WORD IS LIFE
LINE AND THAT'S THE TRUTH IT'S
BEEN- AT SUCH A LIFELINE TO
HAVE BEEN DINING EXPERIENCE FOR
GUESTS DURING THE PANDEMIC AND-
I BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO BE A
CONTINUE THE WHOLE CORPORATE
COVERAGE FOR MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES. I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE TWO SIX FIVE
YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT THIS IS ALAN- SPOKEA
LITTLE EARLY AT THE DATA AND
THAT. IN THE- I WASN'T A LACK
ONE BUT I JUST TO VOICE AGAIN-
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS IS
PLAYED FOR THE- RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY WHERE- OUT AND HAVEN'T
PARTICIPLE COFFEE AS WELL AND-
WE'VE SEEN THE BENEFIT THAT HAS
PLACE FOR- OURSELVES AND SOME
OF THE NEIGHBORING RESTAURANTS
AND- ALL THE GREAT THAT. IN TEN
THIS WOULD BE A HOW AND- COME
MONTHS IN AND OUT THE LONG. SO
I'M IMPOSSIBLE AS WELL. I THANK
COMMENT IN SUPPORT FROM. THREE
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS A NOD AT THAT BY A BIT AND A
HOT COALITION REPRESENTING
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANT LET'S
NOT MAKE OUT. PORT OF THE
EIGHTY FIFTY ONE MEDICO THE
POLICIES AT THE TOP ON ARE NOT
MEMBERS. OF PROGRESSION. OF AN
INDUSTRY NOTED OVER THERE BY
LIKE AN ARMY. HELLO. EACH MONTH
OR AFTER COMMITTING. MORE
PLAQUE. EVEN PAID THAT MAKE.
HAD ONLY WORSE WITH REGULAR
EIGHTY DRUG TO HOP IN THE THAT
MAKE CULTURE THANK YOU FOR OUR
BILL. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MODERATE ARE THERE ANY. MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC IN THE QUEUE FOR A
TO THE AUTHOR BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR HE WAS JUST TAKEN
OFFICE OF AB ONE YOU MAY ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THE STATE. I
NEED TO SEVENTY SIX LINE IS THE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY SCOTT ON ME OF ALCOHOL JUST-
WE ARE OPPOSED TO S. SIXTY ONE
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS- ONE OF
WHICH IS THAT WE BELIEVE IT
TAKES AWAY A LOCAL CONTROL- THE
STATE IS MANDATING OUTDOOR
RESTAURANT APPLICATIONS TO BE
APPROVED WITHOUT DISCRETION.
WHICH MEANS THERE ARE NO PUBLIC
HEARINGS TO BE INVOLVED- WE
FEEL THIS IS- OVERBEARING I'M
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WHO MIGHT
WANT TO REGULATE- SUCH OUTDOOR
SEATING- THEIR OWN. WE ALSO OR-
OBJECTING TO THE PART OF THE
BILL WHICH WOULD CREATE
LICENSING FOR THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY SERVICES. WHILE
CALIFORNIA VERY MUCH NEEDS
LICENSING FOR THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY ON OFF SALE LICENSES
WE ARE FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSED TO
COCKTAILS TO GO. AND THIS
LICENSE- ASPECT OF THIS BILL
WOULD ONLY LICENSE RESTAURANTS-
WITH COCKTAILS TO GO SO WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THAT AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE OPPOSITION Q.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE- MR GABRIEL I
WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS HAVING SPENT
THIRTY YEARS IN THE RESTAURANT
BUSINESS AND HIS MERE IN TWENTY
TWENTY WORKING SO HARD TO TRY
TO KEEP THESE RESTAURANTS A
FLOAT HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO- UTILIZE THE OUTSIDE
AREA FOR BOTH FOOD AND
BEVERAGE- I THINK REALLY GAVE
THEM A LITTLE BIT OF A LIFELINE
AS LONG AS THEY HAD IT SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I WOULD. BE
HONORED TO CO AUTHOR THANK YOU.
VERY HONORED TO HAVE YOUR- ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE- MISTER.
PERCENT THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. JUST WANTED TO
ADD SOME. YES SIR THIRD PARTY
TESTIMONY FROM HER RESTAURANT
IN MY DISTRICT. WHO SAID THAT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
SELL FOOD AND ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES TO GO ALLOW THEM TO
STAY OPEN KEEP THE DOORS OPEN
AND KEEP PEOPLE EMPLOYED- IN
OUR COMMUNITY. AND SO GIVING
THEM NOW THE FLEXIBILITY TO
CONTINUE IN THIS PATH I THINK
IS. A GOOD THING FOR SMALL
BUSINESES ACROSS THE STATE AND
SPECIFICALLY- CORNER OF THE
STATE WHERE ECONOMIC INVESTMENT
ECONOMIC ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES
ARE FEW. TO NONE- TO COME BY SO
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. THANKS SIR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR WHAT COMES. MR
GABRIEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT IF THERE'S
EVER A MOMENT TO GRANT
REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY TO OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES THIS IS THAT
MOMENT AND ON BEHALF OF MARIA'S
ITALIAN KITCHEN A NEIGHBORHOOD
RESTAURANTS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. JENNIFER
TO THE SECOND THIS. CARRILLO
HAND. YOUR CURRENT GUESTS WILL
TAKE THANK YOU FOR EVERYBODY'S
WILLINGNESS TO MOTIONS. MR
GABRIEL WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THIS WONDERFUL MODERATE
APPROACH TO BUSINESS AND-
LOOKING AT FLEXIBILITY IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED TO GO
MOVING FORWARD AND WE'VE ALWAYS
NEED THAT ABILITY. AS A CONDUIT
FOR REPRESENTING OUR OUR
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA THIS
IS UNBELIEVABLE. FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE TO GO FORWARD I
RECOGNIZE THAT WE KNEW WE NEED.
MORE BUSINESS IS SUCCESSFUL.
THE MORE WE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL
HERE. AND HELPING OTHER PEOPLE.
SO WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL. THE MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB SIXTY ONE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
ASSEMBLY HEALTH. FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BERMAN. CORREO AEREO I
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER
AYE DALY. DAVIES DAVIES I
ARSIA- GARCIA AYE GIPSON GIPSON
AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE PORK SILVA PERKS OF
I'D ALMOST. RAMOS I RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SO THAT'S AYE SMITH. SMITH I'D
BE ABLE TO A BE APPROVED BY.
DOES NINETEEN THE BILL HAS
NINETEEN WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
ITSELF THANK YOU SIR VERY MUCH.
OKAY REMOVED FOR TWO MR
PATTERSON'S IN THE HOUSE. WELL
FIRST BY MISTER MARCECA BY MR
COOLEY DO WE KNOW THANK. PLEASE
CHECK THE MOTION ON THE SECOND
THE- ASK YOUR AYE VOTE- VERY
QUICKLY- AB EIGHTY FOUR AS A
BILL WHICH SIMPLY. CHANGE THE
EXISTING REQUIREMENT THAT LARGE
STATE AGENCIESMERELY CONSIDER
CONDUCTING INTERNAL AUDITS AND
INSTEAD MAKE THESE AUDITS
MANDATORY. IT WOULD ALSO
ELIMINATE THE PENCILLING FOR
SOME AGENTS AGENCIES TO KEEP
THESE AUDITS FROM THE PUBLIC.
CURRENT LAW MANY STATE AGENCIES
ARE REQUIRED TO CONSIDER- AUDIT
FUNCTION ONLY HALF OF THE
AGENCIES THAT MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT HAVE DONE SO. THIS
LEAVES NEARLY FORTY AGENCIES
WHICH CONTROL MORE THAN TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN SPENDING
WITHOUT ANY ONGOING JOURNAL
FUNCTION. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION IT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY IN THE ASSEMBLY
ACCOUNTABILITY ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW COMMITTEE WITH ALL
MEMBERS THEIR VOTING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISTER
HARRISON WE HAVING WITNESSES
AND ACCUSED YOU HAVE. WE HAVE
NO WITNESSES. A BIGGER PART THE
WITH NO WITNESSES NO WHAT'S
YOUR WITNESS OKAY SIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO- ANYBODY THE CHAMBER
OF THE HOUSE. SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. SEEING NONE OF THE PUBLIC
AND THE PUBLIC IN THE CHAMBER
IN OPPOSITION TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEEING
NONE BUT AS WE'VE MENTIONED
MANY TIMES BEFORE THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM IS WORKING
TODAY. SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONES- GOING TO THE PHONES FOR
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
N. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU MODERATOR. SO WE'LL
MOVE OVER TO THE COMMITTEE
MEETING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS. OF
THE AUTHOR FOUR COMMENTS.
ESPECIALLY LIKE TO CLOSE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THANK YOU FOR THE
ASSISTANCE OF THAT CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS- REQUEST
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SHE
SAID WE DO HAVE A FIRST AND A
SECOND THAT HAVE BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED- MR PERSON IT'S A
SHAME THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
ACTUALLY DO THIS LAW THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO REQUIRE AN AGENCY
OR SOMEBODY. WHO ACTUALLY. POST
THINGS IN A TIMELY MANNER IN A
TRANSPARENT WAY BUT- THANK YOU
FOR ACKNOWLEDGING THAT HASN'T
BEEN DONE OR NEEDS TO BE DONE.
WITH THAT ALL THE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY. BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHT FOR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED FOR APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW
AYE BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
A. I. BERMAN BERMAN I'VE GOT A-
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY. DAVIES DAVIES
HI GARCIA. GARCIA AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY I
MATHIS. MATHIS I PERK SILVA.
BURKE SELL THE ITEM MOST. RAMOS
I RIVAS. RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH SMITH I'D BE ABLE
TO A BE APPROVED BY. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN. THERE HAS EIGHTEEN
VOTES ITSELF WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE THREE
BILLS LEFT- ARE YOU YEAH MISTER
COOPER YOU PRESENTING FOR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. OKAY
JUSTIN JUSTIN HER ABSENCE
CORRECT. SO WE'RE GOING TO FILE
NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT A. B. SEVEN
SEVEN MISTER COOPER'S PRESENTED
FROM THIS MISERABLE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST AB TEN
SEVENTY WILL PERMIT DISTILLED
SPIRITS MANUFACTURERS THE BILL
YOU PROVIDE UP TO TWELVE
OUTDOOR PATIO UMBRELLAS TO
LOCAL RESTAURANTS. DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE RESTAURANT
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY ONE THE
WORST HIT ECONOMICALLY
RESTAURANTS AND BARS ARE NOW
JUST STARTING TO COME BACK TO
LIFE NOT OR DINING WILL BE
CRITICAL FOR. TO SUCCESSFULLY.
THE CDC IS ENCOURAGING BARS AND
RESTAURANTS TO PRIORITIZE
OUTDOOR DINING AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE RECENTLY A LOCAL TV
STATION SACRAMENTO REPORT THAT
LOCAL RESTAURANTS CREDIT
OUTDOOR DINING PATIOS NOT ONLY
FOR THEIR SURVIVAL DEPENDED ME.
BUT THEY WILL BE KEY TO THE
RECOVERY INCREASING ECONOMIC
SUCCESS I TAKE A MOMENT TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED THIS
BILL SIMPLY HELP GET OUR
RESTAURANTS AND OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES UP ON THEIR FEET
AGAIN ALLEVIATE COSTS FOR THEM
THEY SEEK TO RECOVER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE A WITNESS IN THE ON THE
PHONE MONTEREY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN FOR SHANE LEVINE
ABOUT THE IDEA OF ONE OF THE
WORLD'S LEADING. MANUFACTURERS
WILL PRODUCE ONE THREE B. TEN
SEVENTY. THIS BILL COMES AT A
CRUCIAL TIME WHEN RESTAURANTS
ARE NOW JUST EMERGING FROM THE
PANDEMIC. WITH A FULL RE
OPENING ATTENTIONAL INSIGHT ON
JUNE FIFTEENTH WE SEE THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THOSE
RESTAURANTS ARE ATTEMPTING TO
TRANSITION MUCH OF THE
BUSINESS. WE'RE NOT FOR PATIO
TYPESETTING. MANY RESTAURANTS
OR DINING WAS NEVER
CONTEMPLATED DOES NOT BECOME
REALITY OF DOING BUSINESS AB
CONCERNING ASSEMBLY HELP
RESTAURANTS OFFSETS AND EXPENSE.
MISTER COOPER WE TAKE A NUMBER
MANAGED TO THERE WOULD BE. WE
APPRECIATE FEEDBACK LOOPS FROM
OTHERS. WITHOUT RESPECT ASK MY
BOOK THANK. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WE'RE GONNA ON TO. WIN THIS IS
A SUPPORT OF THE CHAIN. SEEING
NONE WITH WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBER.
SEEING NONE VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM IS. HOPEFULLY TODAY OF
MODERATOR GO TO THE PHONES- FOR
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB AND SEVENTY.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS. ONE TWO SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOT BE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY ONE MOMENT. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN
QUEUE FOUR SUPPORT A. B. CENTER
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL MOVE
OVER TO- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN OPPOSITION. YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB CAN. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LIKE TO SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL SKIP ON BEHALF OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE. WHILE WE ARE
SENSITIVE TO THE SERIOUS
CHALLENGES FACING SMALL
BUSINESSES RECOVERING FROM THE
ECONOMIC DISASTER OF KOBE
NINETEEN. WE ASK THAT YOU NOT
SACRIFICE ESTABLISHED TIED
HOUSE LAWS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
HEALTH AND SAFETY DO SO. THANK
YOU. FURTHER COMMENT IN Q.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. WE HAVE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
ONE MOMENT MISTER JERRY TO HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT THE DOCUMENT YES
PLEASE. ONE TWO SIXTY THREE
ONLINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TO SIXTY THREE YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KEVIN MCCUE
WITH THE DISTILLED SPIRITS
COUNCIL SORRY FOR THE MIX UP
THERE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. FURTHER COMMENT
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. MISTER COOPER WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST WANT TO
ADD A MISTER CHAIR THAT WE'VE
TAKEN THE COMEDIAN AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT.
WE HAD A REFER SECOND. WAS
MATHIS. MISS QUICKSILVER FIRST
AND SECOND- MISTER COOPER THANK
YOU FOR STANDING UP FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE- AND AGAIN
ANY TIME SO WE CAN START
LOOKING AT OPPORTUNITIES TO
HELP PEOPLE. IN BUSINESS AND
THE BUSINESS SECTOR- WE DO
ENCOURAGE THAT MORE. SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL AS YOU SAID IT'S A DO
PASS AS MANY TO APPROPRIATIONS-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY TEN
SEVENTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI. FRAZIER AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BERMAN. BERMAN I CARILLO.
COOLEY R. COOLEY AYE COOPER
COOPER AYE DALY. DAVIES DAVIES
I. ARSIA. GARCIA GIPSON GIPSON
AYE JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE PORK SILVA FOR EXCEL
BUT I KNOW MOST RAMOS I'D RIVAS.
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
SMITH. WE HAVE TO. BE APPROVED
BY. SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN THE
BILL HAS SEVENTEEN THOUSAND THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO SO MR
LOVES LIVE HERE YET SO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE YOU THE
FOOD LAW. VEHICLE. ONE YOUR
FIRST BY MISTER MATHIS. SIX BY
MISTER SALAS. SIR YOU HAVE A DO
PASS I WILL SHARE WITH YOU IN
LESS THAN ONE SUPPORT COULD BE
SOME. BRIEF IN. OKAY YOU KNOW
THAT SORT. PLEASE PRESS SIR
THANK YOU CHAIRED FIRST I WANT
TO START BY THANKING YOU AND
STAFF WORKING WITH MY OFFICE TO
CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE I AGREE TO
TAKE ALL THE SUGGESTED AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS INCLUDING THE
COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. AB ELEVEN FORTY NINE
WILL PERMIT DISTRIBUTORS AND
MERCHANDISE. ALL MORE WINE AND
DISTILLED SPIRITS. READY TO
DRINK BEVERAGES. ACTIVIST IN A
SINGLE SERVING CONTAINERS
CURRENTLY DISTRIBUTORS ARE
PERMITTED TO- TO MERCHANDISE
ONLY BEER AND MALT R. T. D. OUR
TV BEVERAGE PRODUCT. THE NEW
DISTILLED SPIRITS AND WINE
BASED RTDS BEVERAGES ARE
PACKAGED IN THE SAME AS MALL
BASED PARTY BEVERAGES AND ARE
EXTREMELY POPULAR WITH
CONSUMERS- ASSEMBLY AS AMENDED
AB ELEVEN FOURTEEN FORTY NINE
WILL NOMINATE ANY CONFUSION
OVER WHICH ARE TV BEVERAGE ARE
PERMITTED. TO MERCHANDISE BY
DISTRIBUTORS AND WILL CREATE A
LEVEL PLAYING THE LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD ALLOWING DISTRIBUTORS TO
MERCHANDISE ALL OUR TEA
BEVERAGES. AB ELEVEN FORTY NINE
WILL ALLOW SUPPLIERS TO USE
THEIR EXISTING NETWORK AND
DISTRIBUTORS WHO WILL BE
PERMITTED TO MERCHANDISE ALL R.
T. D. BEVERAGES THE SAME AS
BEER WITH ME TODAY. A TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IS DENNIS LOPER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BEER AND BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NIGHT OUT. THANK YOU SIR IS
MISTER. THIS LOCAL OFFICE HERE
HE'S I'M SORRY HE'S HE'S ONLINE
ONLINE YEAH PLEASE PROCEED SIR.
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA THEIR
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS- AND
PROPERTY I WILL SUSPECT THE
POINTS THAT THE SEVEN NUMBER
THE ANALYSIS MAIN- CURRENTLY
THEIR RICHES CAN BE
MERCHANDISED THIS WILL OPEN IT
UP TO A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
DISTILLED AND WINE. PRODUCTS
TODAY ALL- LOOK VERY SIMILAR IN
THE PACKAGING AND WILL- YEAH
ELIMINATE CONFUSION ONE THING
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT. TO
NOTE IS THAT. MCCARTY
DISTRIBUTOR ONLY THE POWER
LOOKS LIKE THEY OWN A CONTROL-
AND WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ON I'M VERY AND ANY
QUESTION. THANK YOU MR ROBERT
ANY OTHER. PEOPLE THE YOUNG A
WITNESS- OKAY. SO WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO THOSE IN THE AND OF THE
AUTHORS BILL WITH LIKE TO.
SHARE THE TEST. THOSE CHAMBER
IN OPPOSITION TO THE- OTHERS
BILL. TO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
TEST MY SINGING. THE NEW
CONFERENCE ROOM IS DOWN TODAY.
MODERATOR TO THE PHONE FOR ME
AND OF THE AUTHORS BILL PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SEVENTY. EIGHT AB ELEVEN FORTY
NINE SORRY ABOUT THAT IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT. ONE THREE ZERO FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN MISSING
MEMBERS TOWARD TOWARDS MILLER
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
BEARS THE BEARS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN FORTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NO FOR THE
MEMBERS. MISTER MEMBERS PRIMARY
SUMMIT HOSPITAL DISTRIBUTE
DIVISION SPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN
YOU LIKE US TO MOVED OPPOSITION.
THIS PLEASES OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOU. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN
FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN
FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND UNDER. WE HAVE NO COMMENT
TO MAKE YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OF
THE OFFER. SEEING NONE SERVICE
LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. I DO HAVE
A FIRST AND SECOND. MISTER
MATHIS SCHOOL MAY AT FIRST AND
SECOND- JUST WANTED TO GET
THANK YOU I MEAN IT'S BEEN A
GREAT DAY FOR PEOPLE SUPPORTING
BUSINESS IN IT AND CREATE AN
EVEN PLAYING FIELD FOR FOLKS OF
THERE'S- A BALANCE. KATE THAT
MEASURE. OF WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE. AS AMENDED YOU DID ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE IMPLEMENT OKAY TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB ELEVEN FORTY NINE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO PASS AS A
MENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
I'VE GOT REAL. COOLEY COOLEY
AYE COOPER COOPER AYE DALY.
DAVIES. GARCIA GARCIA AYE
GIPSON- GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY
I MATHIS. MATHIS I PERK SILVA
FOR EXCEL BUT I'D ALMOST.
RAMESSIDE REVERSED THREE OF US
I'D RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH. SMITH I'D BE
ABLE TO A HI WE HAVE A DRY.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY. THE BILL HAS
EIGHTEEN ITS ALBUM LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR US HAPS ABSENT
MEMBERS MR BERMAN PRESENTING
FOR MR LOW. I DO I DO NINE AB.
FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AB FIFTY THREE WOULD
MAKE ELECTION DAY A STATEWIDE
HOLIDAY IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
200-016-2000 EIGHTEEN GENERAL
ELECTIONS JUST 59% OF ELIGIBLE
VOTERS PARTICIPATED LOWER VOTER
TURNOUT IS A DETRIMENT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY. THE PEW RESEARCH
CENTER HAS FOUND WORK OR SCHOOL
COMPLEX TO BE THE MOST COMMON
REASON CITED FOR NON
PARTICIPATION WELL CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS CALIFORNIANS TO TAKE UP
TO TWO HOURS OFF FROM WORK
WITHOUT LOSS OF PAY TO CAST A
BALLOT ESTABLISHING ELECTION IS
A HOLIDAY WILL MAKE IT EVEN
EASIER FOR CALIFORNIANS. TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR POLITICAL
PROCESS AND GIVE MORE PEOPLE
THE OPPORTUNITYTO VOTE
IMPORTANTLY MAKING ELECTION DAY
A HOLIDAY WILL ALSO SHIFT OUR
CULTURE AROUND ELECTIONS
ELECTION THEY OUGHT TO BE AN
OCCASION TO CELEBRATE OUR
DEMOCRACY WHERE EVERYONE HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOLUNTEER AS
A PORTER TO CAMPAIGN TO OBSERVE
THE VOTING PROCESS AND THE
COUNTING OF BALLOTS. AT THE
MOMENT WHERE THERE IS DEEP
DISTRUST SURROUNDING OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS MAKING
ELECTION DAY A HOLIDAY WILL
HELP PULL BACK THE VEIL ON
ELECTORAL PROCESS AND STILL
CONFIDENCE VOTING SYSTEMS IT IS
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
THIS IMPORTANT STEP OF REDUCING
BARRIERS TO VOTER PARTICIPATION
AND SHIFT THE CULTURE AROUND
ELECTION DAY. WITH ME TODAY TO
ELABORATE FURTHER OR
CHRISTOPHER MAYER WITH ASKED ME
AND MICHELLE OUT A LOSS OR
ALICE THE GENERATION UP. THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK ANOTHER.
MISTER MAYOR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBER. OKAY GO AHEAD.
PLEASE. SORRY ABOUT THAT-
WITHOUT MERIT CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES. AB FIFTY THREE WILL
COMPLEMENT THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
THE POLLS BY DECLARING ALL
ACTION MAY BE HOLIDAY EVEN WITH
EARLY VOTING AND VOTING BY MAIL
MANY PEOPLE WISH TO VOTE IN
PERSON ON ELECTION DAY. AND
OTHERS STILL HAVE LOGISTICAL
ISSUES ARE DEMOCRATS IN EIGHT
EIGHTY FIFTY THREE WILL PUPIL
PRIA COMPLICATED TO BECOME
POINT CENTERS ON ELECTION DAY
IN COUNTY HAVE NOT UPDATED TO
THE VOTERS TOWARD. AT MEMBER
BERMAN. THANK FIFTY THREE WILL
ALSO FREE UP VOLUNTEERS TO WORK
THE POLE. AND DEPORTER HURTS
WHICH WILL BE A GREAT SERVICE
TO OUR STATE IN A KIND OF
COORDINATED MISINFORMATION.
REGARDING THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTION SYSTEM. UNFORTUNATELY
DATE COULD NOT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO REQUIRE ALL BUSINESSES TO
CLOSE ON ELECTION DAY THAT THIS
IS AN AREA WHERE THE STATE
LAGGED BEHIND THE GREAT
COMMUNITY I'VE NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE THAT ALEX'S
MANY COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING AN
ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY. TO
EMPLOYEES. THE ENACTMENT OF AB
FIFTY THREE WILL FURTHER DRAW
ATTENTION TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
VOTING AND CIVIC PARTICIPATION
AND STRENGTHEN THE ARGUMENT FOR
OTHER COMPANIES AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO OBSERVE ELECTION
DAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHELLE HELLO I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR MARKET HIGH
SCHOOL AND WALNUT CREEK THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
CHARACTER ABOUT THE STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE NOT
TERRIBLY INEFFECTIVE DISTRICT
AS WELL HOPE YOU DIRECTOR FOR
JOBS THE ORGANIZATION I'M
RECOMMENDING. THAT WHERE YOU
DON'T KNOW NONPROFIT DEDICATED
TO ORGANIZING AND ADVOCATING
FOR AGAIN TUITION BETTER IN OUR
HEALTH EDUCATION. WE ARE A BOB.
OF. EIGHTY FIFTY. AB FIFTY
THREE OF A JOB AMONG BILL CAL.
NOTING AT THE OF AVENUE PEOPLE
DIRECTLY ACCESS THE DEMOCRATS
RIGHTS AND CHANGE AND ARE. AND
HELP HOPING THE FROM THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE. EACH
ELECTION HELD ON TUESDAY DURING
THE WORK DAY REBEL AND LYFT
PEOPLE GOING TO THE POLLS
DESPITE THOSE ABSENTEE VOTING.
LONG COMMUTES CHILDREN WORKING
DAY JOBS CAN PREVENT VOTERS
FROM HEADING TO THE POLLS.
TRANSACTION DATE THE WHITE
HOLIDAYS WOULD TURN VOTING INTO.
A CELEBRATION OF DEMOCRACY. SHE
FURTHER MY THIS MAKES IT FOR TO
AND GETTING THE VOTE. OCTOBER
AT WAS YOUR THE HOLLYWOOD OPEN
UP TALK TO LOW. I THANK HIM FOR
IN KNOWING THAT THINGS CAN WERE
THE BALL ABOUT WHAT ABOUT
MISSING CALCUL OR HISTORY THAT
DAY. BUT THINK CURRENTLY
WORKING MUCH THAT. AND MARK BY
WILL COME. AND AN OUTCOME IN
AND OUT OF THE QUESTION. AT THE
REVEREND OF ACTIVATING. ALONG
PARENTS TO BRING CHILDREN THANK
YOU POLLS. WHAT BEEN CAPITAL
AND EXERCISE. I THANK ALL
BOXING AND FALL THANK YOU
TAKING IN GETTING OUT THE VOTE
THE TWENTY TWO ELECTION. THE
PRESSURE UNDER THE IMPORTANT TO
ME IN MY IN YOUNG PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE FOR OF BOTH.
MISSPELLING MAKING HIM FOR THE
EASIER QUESTION OF ALL AND BE
MORE. ENGAGE BACKING A CULTURE
AND A CHEN. OF AND INTELLIGENT
BUILDING. AND I'M NOT BY MYSELF
TO BE OLD ENOUGH TO THAT I KNOW
THAT HOW WILL MAKE IT SIMPLE
AND EXPRESS FOR ME TO DO SO.
WRAP THIS UP PLEASE. THANK YOU
I THINK IF I REMEMBER LOCAL IN
THE SPELL AND I ACTUALLY AFTER
I THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MODESTO THE CHAIN. IF THERE'S
ANY SUPPORT- WATERS BECAUSE OF
THE AUTHORS BILL MEASURE. OTHER
ANY BODY IN THE- THAT IS THE
CHAMBER WOULD LIKE SPEAKING UP
TO THE AUTHORS. SING NINE. OF
EITHER. SO YOU HAVE A ROOM IS
DOWN TO. SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE PHONE MONTEREY FOR PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT OF HIS OFFICE. THANK
YOU CHAIR IF YOU WISH SPEAK AND
OF FIFTY THREE YOU MAY BE ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. THREE
YOU MIGHT ONE. AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE THREE TWO YOU KNOW
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
FOR THE LIGHTING IN THE
UNIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA'S SAYS
HE- STRONG OF A- GREAT. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON LONG LOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION THE OFFICIAL FOR
DAILY HALF A MILLION HE
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL SUPPORT OF
AB. FIFTY THREE. NINE THREE
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAE IS
KATHERINE WHEN YOU DID IT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY AND
I SUPPORT EIGHTY FIFTY THREE.
AND ONE MOMENT FOR LAST MONTH.
WE HAVE NO MORE RESPONSIVE AND
KEEP. SO CAN WE MOVE OVER TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THIRD
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
PLEASE. IT'S JUST TAKEN A
POSITION OF AB FIFTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
ABOUT HIS BILL. SEEING NONE MR
BERMAN CHUCK CLOSE RESPECT
ESCRIBO. BERMAN WE HAVE A FIRST
OR SECOND ON THIS ONE. WHO WAS
IT. HAS IT ARE YOUR CURRY'S
FIRST. RIVAS IS SECOND. THANK
YOU SO MUCH BOTH OF YOU- THIS
BERMAN THANK YOU FOR STEPPING
IN FOR MR LOW. AND THIS PREVENT
PRIVATE THREE YEARS IN A ROW
HOPEFULLY IT'S TIME FOR THIS
THING THE MOVE FORWARD OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS. THE FOURTEENTH
AT. FOUR TIMES GIVES ME. NOW
SUPPORT YES. THANK YOU FOR THE
CORRECTION- HELP IN SUPPORT OF
MR NINE SPEAKER SPEAKER WELL
SERVICE PLEASE. HELLO YEAH FILE
ITEM NINE AB FIFTY THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOW AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN BERMAN
I GOT RADIO. COOLEY COOPER
COOPER AYE DALY. DAVIES GARCIA.
GARCIA GIPSON GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER. LACKING LATINO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO PARQUE SILVA. FOR
EXCEL BUT I'D ALMOST. MEMBERS
I'D RIVAS. RIVERSIDE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH.
SMITH NOVEMBER DRAW WE HAVE TO
DO A. PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN.
TWELVE LEAVE IT OPEN- HAS
TWELVE MOVES OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR UP SOME MEMBERS.
SYNCING WHERE WE'RE AT NOW AT
THIS POINT ALL WELL BILLS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED- WE DID IF WE
DID THAT THANK YOU FOR DOING
AGAINST THOSE VERY THOROUGH I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
THOROUGHNESS FOR THOSE THAT
WERE HERE ON TIME HEY WOULD
YEAH. SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND THAT'S OKAY WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE
CALL. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BERMAN BERMAN I CARILLO.
GALLAGHER JONES SAWYER. QUICK
SILVA RICK. SEN COUNTERS OUT.
FILE ITEM ONE AB FIVE FIVE NINE
COOLEY. COOPER. RIGHT OKAY.
GIPSON. I KNOW YOU DID WAS THE
FIRST ONE. GIPSON HI. THE BILL
IS OUT. LOOKING AT CALLS WIRED.
YES. ON ALL. IF YOU HAVE LITTLE
MODELS BETTER FOR THE. NO IT'S
OKAY I CAN YOU CAN STAY THERE
AND ALL THE ROLL ON THE
CALENDAR COUNTRY. CARILLO I.
JONES SAWYER OPTIONS HI. MY
ITEM ONE AB. FIVE NINE. YEAH.
VIOLATE TO A TWO FORTY TWO OUR
HAN JONES SAWYER OPTIONS I
DON'T. FILE ITEM FOR A TWELVE
SEVEN THANK YOU CUNNING BERMAN.
BERMAN I JONES. JONES SAWYER I.
FIRELIGHT FIVE EIGHT SIX ONE
GABER DALY. FOR ITEM EIGHT AB
TEN CARILLO. AREA I DALY. RIVAS
I HAD ON AN AND I ADDED ON AS
AN ITEM OUT. FILE NINE AB FIFTY
THREE LOW GOT. GUARDIOLA COOLEY.
DALY DAVIES. JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THAT THOSE OUT. FILE
ITEM TEN AB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
PATTERSON CORREO. CORREO HI
DALY. RIVAS RIVAS I HAVE TO
LOSE OUT FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB.
ELEVEN FORTY NINE BE A GOOD
WALK IDEA. THREE OH FIVE DALY.
DAVIES BILLS OUT. IN THE
SCHOOL- THEY HAVE LIKE- THE
BEACH. THAT FILE ITEM FIVE AB
SIXTY BERMAN BERMAN I. OKAY
MISTER THANK YOU. EIGHT OKAY
WHAT. YEAH. YEAH GREAT MICHAEL
WHAT IS THIS PLACE RIGHT. THAT
ENDED. OKAY. ONE GET TO KEEP UP
WITH IT- THREE TO FIVE. SHE
WENT SEE THAT. YEAH A COUPLE
THE PROPOSAL IF YOU'RE
SATISFIED WITH THE- YEAH. DONE
TO SET YOU COULD LOOK AT- THIS
PART. ADJOURNMENTS YEAH. HOW
MANY OF THESE TOGETHER WHEN
TRANS L. A. DALE YOU A LOT.
YEAH YEAH IT IS DIFFERENT IN
HERE BRITISH. VEHICLE IS THIS
IS MORE SO IT'S MORE. YOU IN.
FOR CALLING HER AND EXACT. AND
STANDPOINT TO KEEP OF. OKAY YOU
CAN'T GET ANY FLOW OF THE
THERE'S NO NO THERE'S A IN
EVERYTHING TO WE DO IT LIKE I
DON'T LIKE THANK YOU MICHAEL
THANK BROWN. FOR MORE ORDER.
ALL RIGHT LET'S DOUBLE DOWN
OKAY. THIS MEETING OF THE
ORGANS COMMITTEE WILL NOW BE A
J.